In President Trump's impeachment trial,
senators swore to do impartial justice.
How can they keep such an oath? How can
partisan senators be impartial?
They have to understand two things: what's on
trial and what the Senate was created to be.
First, what is on trial? The president,
but also the impeachment itself.
The Constitution empowers the Senate to try
impeachments, so the Senate must consider
not just factual questions, but legal and
Prudential questions too. Second, what was
the Senate created to be? A counterweight
to both the House and the president.
The founders expected the Senate to embody a
mix of accountability and statesmanship.
It's meant to temper the passions of the
House in passing laws and to play
a significant role in the president's
administration of domestic laws and
foreign policy. An impeachment trial is
the Senate's ultimate opportunity to
serve both those roles when they are needed most.
That is the impartial justice that
impeachment calls upon them to do.
Impeachment does not need the Senators
to transform into jurors.
It needs senators to become, truly, the Senate.
In impeachment, can the Senate
and the House be truly impartial?
Let us know in our poll.
Also let us know what other topics
you'd like to see our scholars cover in
60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.